how to do it better with GP how to roll
up your pants the right way so you
decide to roll up your pants most
important thing to do is tailor your
role to the pair of pants you're wearing
that and oh-ho-oh don't look like you're
apt to see looking for clamps here's how
to do it better one you're wearing
stiffer jeans go over the James Dean
one simple cuff two inches max your
jeans are still pulling at your ankles
have your tailor hem them to the right
length you want them to just skim the
tops of your shoes two for the khakis
and light washed beat to hell jeans a
more casual roll will do the trick
you want to look accidental but you know
excellent - so grab an inch worth of leg
and roll once then tease them a bit so
they're not looking too practiced you
got it baby three four suit pants
oh no head to the tailor have your
tailor add a cup an inch and a half is
our standard it looks best tailored 1/2
inch or so above your kicks order of
advice this move works best on wintry
fabrics like tweeds or corduroys
you